My name is Nathan.
I'm just want to thank everyone for
showing up and your patients today. Oh,
we got this awesome little event.
Go on today on it is my pleasure and
honor to introduce Jessica Lay Mayfield.
She had time on her tour to come stop by
and talk with us for a little bit so we
can learn about her past and what kind
of brought her here today and we'll end
up like a little set.
Hopefully have some beautiful songs and
maybe some Q and a but as we go. But um,
yeah. Hello. How are you doing today?
Yay.
Yeah, I am. I am doing well.
Thanks for having me here.
Is this,
are we under like a giant guitar?
I think so, yeah. We're
hoping that you'll,
the finale will be somehow incorporated
into that guitar, but we'll get there.
We'll get there. Yeah.
Excellent. Well, um,
you have such a long kind of career,
even though you're kind of like,
it's a short career.
Like you started in a family
band and like I was like a child,
like this seems kind of
like a very interesting
opportunity and kind of a way to
kind of adapt and kind of
guide your musical career.
Would you mind telling us
a little bit about that?
Oh, okay. Well yeah,
I've been doing this
for a really long time,
so I started doing music with my parents
when I was eight years old and we lived
on a old tour bus that was owned by a
bunch of popular bluegrass and country
musicians at one point and basically
just travel around like hippies.
And so I've been touring since
I can remember basically.
That's amazing. Like I can only imagine
just kind of being on the road one,
but let's put the family to dynamic.
Like that could be very interesting
kind of relationship to kind of roll was
born with.
And then also just kind of take that
musical experience as a positive and keep
moving with.
I think it just Kinda,
it definitely made, um,
really, it just kind of made
everyone feel like they're,
there weren't really family
roles. It was just like, okay,
we're all on the same level here are
doing the same thing. Sort of, you know,
I'm real,
I'm just traveling around trying
to make money and you know,
so it's just really interesting to
feel like you were on a team with your
relatives are awesome idea.
You guys take you and your brother take
that street corner and your mom and I'll
go over here and let's all play for tips
and come back and see what we got and
it's interesting.
So definitely an interesting,
awesome,
wait,
was there like a favorite song or like
kind of like a goto track that you guys
had it together or maybe it was like
the one you guys enjoy doing the most?
Usually.
I mean we pick kind of one song,
whatever song seemed to be trying
to remember right now. I was,
a lot of times it would be requests so
people would want to hear stuff like
amazing grace. It didn't feel like
okay, I was just like a little girl.
I'm like wow.
Right.
Awesome. Awesome. Well you know obviously
in your musical career denied in there.
I've kept moving.
And then 2006 about if my memory serves,
that's when I'm white lies came out.
That is kind of when I was
first introduced to you and
your music while you were
a tournament,
the Everett brothers and that was a
beautiful summer of Oh seven I was very
happy to meet you there.
But that was kind of the legend goes that
that was the album that kind of got a
particular artist, that
tension. And if I have a right,
the gentlemen from Black Keys, Dan,
our buck. And then what happened?
What snowballed from there?
Well, he's from Akron, Ohio
and I'm from Kent, Ohio.
When I had recorded that
album at home in a bedroom,
it ended up getting over to him somehow.
And then from there we started recording
just me and I've a couple of times a
week and recording, not really
knowing what it was going to be.
And then I ended up making my first
record with him and then I made my second
record with him as well.
How will that, cause at that time
he could have been what a teenager,
I would one would guess it'd could be
a very kind of unique kind of guiding
experience for like a young artist to
meet someone and kind of, you know,
that's a big name,
you know,
like an adult coming to you and
wanting to produce and push your music.
That seems like pretty magical.
I know it was definitely
interesting to kind of,
I had a lot of friends at the time who,
who knew who they were,
who the black keys were,
and I was just kind of,
I got hip to it around the time that I
met him and that was around the time that
they were really starting to
get more popular. So I thought,
you know, okay, I'll go
hang out with the sky,
I guess in work in his studio
and then it'll be whatever.
But it definitely ended up, uh, you know,
I still to this day I
meet a lot of people who,
the first album they heard is the
first one that I did really with dance.
So I think that there's still people
that are going back and finding out about
me now throw it out. And that came out
over 10 years ago. Right. Almost the sense
that's crazy.
I kind of did the reverse.
Like I heard that you were doing backup
vocals on like some kind of like sloppy
Jamey like blues band. I was
like, oh, I should check it out.
And then that's when I find that
you did the backup vocals for um,
things aren't like they
used to be, right? Yeah.
And that was kind of out of the reverse
kind of interaction with the black.
He was like, oh, like who is she playing
with? Oh, okay. Right on this, this week.
These guys are good. Yeah. Awesome.
Well then from there we'll,
so the next time when we came out with
them with blossoming was so heartfelt.
That was kind of like our first
kind of major produced album.
Not you and your brother kind of
slow for frilliest produced. Like,
how was that kind of new experience
from like family jam band panell stuff,
you know,
like on your own to kind of like this
more kind of potentially like dynamic or a
specific process?
You know,
it's funny,
I definitely um,
with blast for me it was kind of piece
together over a period of time where Dan
had this rental space and he would get
in different gear and Kennan call me over
10 to Guinea pig and try stuff out.
And then stuff from the became that album,
which is,
it's funny because then by the
time I did my next album with him,
it was real studio vibes. But that
first thing was just kinda like, uh,
all right,
one of us has to like reach over and
turn this machine on and then get back to
whoever's closer to it and,
and who isn't starting the song first.
So it was very still kind of,
I feel like with blasphemy.
So has those bedroom
me vibes of just like,
hey,
we're using nicer stuff.
But it's just like very small group of
people that we can't even really say
group
was there. Like any kind of
like intimidation level with it.
Like obviously you've been around music
and performers as like a young kid.
So like what's it, it's just like
another day at the office there.
Was there kind of like a an all
moment and involved in it at all?
Um, I mean not, not really. I don't
get it. That's interesting though.
I don't really get too
nervous around people.
Good for you. It was great power.
More like single people? No,
like a large group of people maybe.
I don't know.
That sounds bad.
Awesome.
Well kind of brought up favorite brothers
earlier and like definitely have seen
you guys tour.
Like anytime you guys go harmony,
it's the most beautiful thing
ever. Well Scotty, so much.
And so you guys have this awesome
Elliot Smith tribute album that's just
beautiful and gorgeous and I can see
obvious that Elliot Smith as a potential
enemies, the ones are on you,
but kind of curious what,
what led you to this specific
project and also with Scott? David.
Oh it was with that. Seth, I'll stop.
Sorry. Pardon me. That's okay.
They were actually people that would
come to the show and still think that was
Scott,
which I don't get,
I think people confuse them just a little
bit part of my nerves. No, that's okay.
Whatever.
Um,
uh, we, uh, south,
I realized that we were both big Elliot
Smith fans and that was just something
we would end up talking about almost
every time we saw each other until one
point we were on tour together and we
both walk into the screen room and it had
a piano.
And when he started playing an Elliot
Smith Song and I started singing it and
from there we were like,
we should do something like this.
And we just kept sending each other the
voice memos of Elliot Smith songs until
we had an more than enough ideas.
That's very cool.
And slowly out of them.
I was always trying to put my finger on
like a way to kind of describe it and I
kind of stumbled upon a review that kind
of just said it so well too where like
it wasn't like you guys trying to reinvent
or like change the songs and make it
your own. It was more just kind of
like an honest homage to Elliot Smith.
Like does kind of like put it all into
like a wonderful nutshell for me when I
was like thinking of that album, like
how you guys put it together. Huh?
Well thank you.
It's,
it was kind of stressful because
especially as huge Elliot Smith Fans,
I think we understood
that, you know, you're,
you're attempting to mess with something
that's pretty delicate and s and I had
to put myself in the shoes of,
if someone else did that would I be like,
what are you doing anyway? You can't
sing Elliot Smith songs. Like, no,
there's only he can do that. You
know, he's the best of that. So right.
There's definitely that line to draw of
wanting to do a good enough job to do it
justice without making it
too different or you know,
ruining it somehow.
I think we just didn't want to ruin it.
Well, whatever level you
found, it was wonderful.
And thank you for that version of fun.
We're a fun for all of her friends is
just, it gets me, it's very beautiful.
Thank you. Yeah. All right. What else
do I have to harass you with? Anyone?
Compliments.
That's what the last pages.
I just have a list of things I like about
Shia so we'll get there. Don't worry.
Yeah. Yeah. Um, well we have your
newest album. I'm sorry. It was gone.
Um, it's very interesting album for me.
It felt like there was a lot more, like,
just seems like there's
so much happening though,
but it flows together really
well. Like it, no, I do like that,
but this is why I'm bringing it up.
But I'm like,
just like this kind of
rawness to it within it.
Like it's not like it's scattered.
It flows for me,
but it does have like a
different depth for me.
And then when I saw the title of sorry,
it was gone.
I was wondering if that was kind of like
kind of reflection of the steps that
you were trying to like kind of create
or maybe project with it because it's
such a kind of simple sings a little,
let's just, sorry it's was gone,
but it seems like there's kind
of a lot behind it potentially.
Well,
I mean I think this album,
it came together without
me really realizing what if
any theme there was going
to be.
And I realized that a lot of the songs
were all working together for the theme
of being,
uh,
not afraid to be yourself,
I guess,
which is all these things sound cheesy
and funny, but it's, I don't know,
you shouldn't be embarrassed
to talk about them.
Yeah.
And that's one of beautiful and I think
that's kind of this variation of style.
And I kind of comes in is producing this
all one kind of reflects what you're
just saying. I'm just like that genuine
self, which funnel is really awesome.
I was just curious about the title and
like maybe how it played with it. Okay,
sweet. Yeah. Alrighty.
Well I have some more kind of just like
a silly question is for you if we may
and we can lighten the mood a little bit
before we hear some of your banks and
your music
ask away.
So like I feel like there was always
someone at shows we just kind of want to
scream and I'm like song
or request at you. Okay.
So like is there like any in particular
that have stood out over the years that
kind of made me cracked a smile
or maybe or even like indulged?
Hmm.
See I don't think I've ever had anyone
like requests unless it's my song and
they requested that I might play it,
but it's like one thing,
people will go back with my
songs and I'll go really,
really far to the very,
very first album.
And what lives don't want to hear
something that's more than 10 years old or
that I wrote when I was like 15,
I'm thinking, I don't remember that
there was this one show where I had played
and then came back up for the encore
and we were all getting ready
to play our hearts around.
This drunk woman comes up
and she goes, no, stop. And
she's like, where? She's like,
you're going to play this song. And
it was like some really slow, weird,
sad song off of white
lies. And I'm like, no,
this is the last song of the night.
It has to be something fun.
And like she got really
mad and stormed out.
That's probably a more interesting thing.
I think people get really emotional.
If I don't do that,
they ask me,
well you, you're there for them, right?
Yeah. Like I'm sorry, like I have a plan,
like a list of songs to do.
The band learned
and I promise this one wasn't
like, you know, like, uh, a
temperamental question. I,
I didn't bring it up like on the spot,
but I was wearing if over
the years of touring,
I'm sure you kind of come across a lot
of interesting to silly to like comical,
like interactions or obstacles.
I'm wondering if you have like maybe
like one that comes to mind that like
brings the biggest smiles
or last as you look back,
obstacles, just silly
things, you know, like
travel and every day on the
road cars, you know, there,
there could be always trouble out there.
Right?
Oh,
there's always trouble out there.
Like booking a hotel in the wrong city
and then driving to the right city and
realizing it later.
I'm trying to think of what kind of
goofy snafu that happened.
I don't know.
It's actually kind of boring honestly.
I mean it's just kinda like hotel,
like sitting in a hotel,
eating that sounds nice.
Eating in bed, uh, playing
a rock show, eating in bed.
Maybe if I'm lucky,
I can like lay in bed before
the show too if I have,
this is where it gets really exciting.
Um,
just any basically just like eating and
sleeping and it's people things driving.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Well, can I get up kind of like on
the same level, like is there like a,
a group or an artist that you've enjoyed
and it was kind of touring or it's been
kind of like a special or fun experience?
Well, it's funny you mentioned
it's the ava brothers.
I kind of look back on that is that was
some of the first touring that I did.
It was with them and with the black keys
and I was really young and that was the
first time I ever did any west coast
touring was with the avid brothers.
So there's definitely a lot of first
time tour things with them that I always
think about. So that's,
that's fine because I'll go
somewhere to be like, oh yeah,
I've been here a million times now.
But I remember the first time I came here.
Yeah.
Sweet. Very cool. Yeah.
And then how about like what
are you listening to these days?
And if there was like,
if you're, you know,
trying to like sit in a bed and
eat some food in a hotel room,
like what do you put on?
Okay, well let's see. Put on,
I don't really watch much TV
music. Is that what you
listen to it? Yeah. Yeah.
Um, and music wise it's
always, it's funny,
I don't really branch out very much.
I keep it till like the
same group of artists.
So it's always like Elliot Smith and um,
Saligoe Soundgarden,
just a nineties,
nineties classics heavy, a lot
of heavy music. Awesome. Um,
I've been trying to listen to some books
on tape, but it's hard to say a week,
so it's not a good thing to do while
driving, but I still try to do it anyways.
And then if you fall asleep,
I get listening today in bed and you're,
you don't retain any of it. So still
trying to figure out books on tape.
It'll be there for you.
There'll be waiting.
How that,
how that works.
Awesome. Well, you know,
I just wanted to kind of spend some time
to kind of like share your pass and you
hear where you're coming from.
I'm like, why you're here today.
Like maybe now it'll be a good time
to treat everyone with their patients.
Will see a few tracks and then maybe a
little Q and a at the end if that's all
right by you. Yeah. Beautiful.
Hold on. I'm going to receive
from the stage. Oh yes.
Believe me. I'll sit here if you'd
like. Yeah. It will be your room.
I can be the water. Yeah. Well I'm
gonna sit here and be the water boy.
You're welcome to sing along. Oh
God, I might on that accident.
There's a show tonight.
Yeah. Oh, of course. Pardon?
I should know about that cause
levy singing at the show tonight.
I will be singing at the show tonight
tonight at the independent will get to see
full set from the lovely Tuscola. May
take us are slow, probably available.
And if you have nothing to do
and you should come and join us.
Yeah.
To practice.
[inaudible]
sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry,
sorry, sorry, sorry.
Sorry.
Can understand.
Safe to say,
Eh,
this space without feeling,
sorry. It's gone. Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
It's gone.
Shit,
Shane too.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay. So, oh,
sorry.
So the,
sorry, it's gone. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. It's gone.
The Sari,
the Sari.
[inaudible]
please leave me alone.
Yeah.
The depths in the day.
Sure,
sure.
No car
you love
is could love
for sure.
For sure.
Kenna.
Good
class.
Oh my goodness. If I go, I would
hate to say something too old.
I would hate to not, I've had four
today stuck in my head for a minute.
I don't want to hear that. If
you would, I would not. Yeah,
I would do that for you.
Goodness. All right. Yes,
please. It is. It's going back
pretty fun. That's best for Nathan
to the beginning. Beginning.
Goodness. Thank you guys.
Hm?
Yeah.
Oh,
the sky.
So you miss me.
No.
Swoons masons.
Sweet. Ah, Kay.
Kay.
So batch
and
say please.
Close to fun.
So home
this
situation
clean.
Um,
so
the word to say the phone,
because there's nothing to say.
Yeah.
Say
the same thing.
Ah,
Yay.
Nay
say
close to fun.
Oh,
thank you for keeping that in my
head for the next week or two.
What do you think? She was a little
break for us in the Q and. A.
You want to keep it? You want me to
play more? Do you have more questions?
I kind of ran through my questions.
Maybe we can do a little Q and a then it
some more songs. Yeah, totally beautiful.
I could play a song. Why you asked
me a question? Yeah, let's do it.
This just started asking me,
come up with something.
There was a microphone in the back of the
room for those of us who would like to
ask Jessica some questions.
Okay. Now Watch me awkwardly
dancing around the stage.
Hi.
Hello.
Well you sound great.
I wanted to ask, uh, what you
find most gratifying about your,
your career?
Is it making music and touring or is it
putting an album out or meeting super
fans?
Like anything.
Those are all great points.
I think there's something
too about it can be, it's,
it's interesting to,
I really liked the personal process of
writing songs and then I feel like the
process of sharing them
almost goes against what it
is because it's definitely a
really private,
uh,
collection of feelings and then I
go out and share them with everyone.
So there's kind of those two
different aspects, which I,
I like getting, you know, to
have to have the contrast.
Wow.
Thank you. Yeah. Did you
share them? Whites worst.
Ooh. Um, I'm kind of weird like that.
So if I'm gonna work on it with someone,
then I would play it for them. Otherwise,
if I'm just working on something,
I might just play it at a
show and see what happens.
And I try it once and if I don't like
it then I'm just never play it again.
Otherwise,
if I liked something about it,
then it might make it's way
into something eventually.
Yeah. Red. Thank you.
Hi, mixed. No, I'm just kidding. On A,
we'll waive its subject of have a
new groups here for songwriters,
producers and musicians.
And a topic that frequently comes up
is the difficulties of the songwriting
process and finishing what you start.
Uh,
I'm wondering what you can share
with us about your own process and
difficulties you might even still have.
Yeah,
I think that it's, um, it's easier,
it's easy to realize that something might
not be that great of an idea if you're
having a really hard time finishing it.
So I think the,
the thing about that is to make sure
you were excited enough by the idea to
follow through. And that's something I've
learned is if that's not how you feel,
then make yourself feel that way if you,
cause if I,
if I'm not wanting to follow through
on an idea, I have to ask myself,
why am I procrastinating
on it? And just like, oh,
because I'm not that passionate about it.
So I think for me that's his main thing
is to just keep finding ways to stay
excited about what you're working on.
Thank you very much. Yeah. Thank you.
That's like a weird city hall.
It's just big on actually no,
we are building the road.
I am building the shooting range next
to the playground. I'm just kidding.
All right.
Hi.
So on that same topic,
I'm wondering,
do you write your lyrics first
and the music or vice versa?
That changes, you know,
something I go through phases.
She usually lyrics first and sometimes
I'll come up with a melody that I really
like and I'll hate the lyrics and then
I'll put lyrics that I wrote previously
to that.
But it's definitely two different things.
I'll write something and either I'll
really like the lyrics or the melody and
then work from there. Decide what is
it about that that I liked? Was it the,
the way I was it, was it the word service
of the way that I was saying the words
you have someone who you collaborate with,
how do we get a little bit?
MMM,
yeah.
No, I mean I don't collaborate
that, that often as far as,
I'm kind of bad about that with song
writing and if I do, I just have to, um,
a lot of times it's give a song to
someone else and leave them alone with it.
I definitely can't watch while
someone else tears it apart.
It's hard to be open minded to, you have
to, once you hear someone else's idea,
it's hard to immediately not just be
like, I hate it. It's not my idea.
You have to actually try to see what,
what could be good about it, you know,
just because it's someone else's idea.
Yeah.
You're welcome.
These are good for thanks again
for a performance this afternoon.
Thank you.
You mentioned you've,
uh,
you've had like a whole life and
career in the music industry and uh,
you started out the corners shows
and mean back to the family.
You've seen a lot of the music industry
change over the years as well. Um,
and I'm wondering if you could share,
if you have any chronic sort of like
gripes with where the music industry is
today, where you might see
improvements in the future,
kind of what you'd like to see
in the future for the music industry.
Interesting. Yeah. It's
weird. It's Kinda like,
I don't really have unnecessary
like an idea to fix it,
but you can see what's happening and
it's been happening for most of my life.
I mean,
I can look back to
music being free when I was 10,
11,
12 and in remembering like Napster and
all this stuff and seeing that even as
we're kind of watching that happen and
watching people that you said to make
money,
doing something that having people not
really want to invest in it anymore.
And I guess that's something that I'm,
I've kind of seen,
seemed the way things have
changed. It's just not, I dunno,
but I didn't really see the way
things were at the same time too.
So it's an interesting,
um,
I'm really curious to see where it goes,
but I have no idea how I
could even imagine that
because who knows what's going
to keep changing.
Yeah. Yeah. You're welcome. Thank you.
I was looking for advice
on how not to lose this.
So specifically that was
when you were in love. Okay.
And when you read a lot of solid and
it's a great song and then you break up,
what do you do with that love song that
reminds you of that person to lose it?
Right. Do you have a way of taking
it back and the two years ago?
Oh yeah. You just, you keep
singing it and new definitely. Um,
apply it to something
else. I don't know. It's
try,
I mean give it some time if you have too,
but I mean if you, especially
if you really liked the
song and just be like, hey,
you know what,
the one cool thing I got out
of this was this red sung,
you know,
we got it that way.
Like just kind of instead of
thinking about her or whatever,
whoever it is
like,
yeah, definitely. I mean, I,
I'm kind of a relationship writer too,
so it's, I definitely write about
every relationship that I've been in.
And then eventually it goes
back to when I was a teenager.
So there's a lot of teenage breakup
set I still ended up singing about,
and I think that's ridiculous as
this is part of my life and career,
but it's, you know, it's like, hey,
at least they got the part of my life
and career out of this relationship.
So cool.
Awesome.
Thank you guys.
Cool.
How do you feel choir music?
I could do more music.
Hi.
Thank you. Oh yeah, thank you.
Awesome.
Hmm.
Yes.
No,
it's say
okay.
No
insane.
Yes.
Okay.
Huh?
Yes.
No,
it's say Si.
Okay.
No,
it's say
no,
no.
Okay.
Yeah. Everyone's going
to pay you. Yeah. Cool.
I do like one more than you guys
can get back to your life and those,
you would just normally
be sitting here like this.
Would you all be facing this
direction? Usually here. All Day. Okay,
cool.
Thanks for letting me sit in front of you.
I appreciate it.
Hmm.
If
God
for the
good girl,
which she same name
but no on.
See Man,
I wish she could see me
now that no one can see me.
Okay.
It's
the other side.
Good girl,
good girl.
Which she is same,
but no one can see me.
Oh is she kids?
Same main.
Now the no one can.
Same Day man.
Wish she could see me.
No one can see me.
She seen me now the no on his same name.
Thank you so much to everyone for being
here and supporting this wonderful day.
And hopefully this is first of many.
Of course,
many thanks to Jessica for finding time
in between tourism and shows and drive
in life to come stop by with us.
So another round of applause for justice.
Gotcha.